[Musique]
nous aurions souhaité aller encore plus
loin au niveau de la proximité c'est un
peu la philosophie nous avons défendu au
sénat représentant 50 propositions à
l'été dernier pour faire en sorte que la
prise de décision finalement
se fasse au plus proche de nos
concitoyens nous considérons
qu'aujourd'hui le mouvement de
décentralisation de déconcentration
aussi une différenciation doit
s'accélérer convaincu que les françaises
et les français attendent à ce que tout
ce qui relève de leur quotidien soit
décidée dans leur département dans leur
commune dans leur région et non plus
nécessairement ici à paris
non cette loi clairement ne va pas assez
loin on l'a dit c'est une loi
d'ajustement ce n'est pas une grande loi
de déconcentration on a besoin ou
décentralisation on a besoin d'un
mouvement beaucoup plus puissant en
france de décentralisation et
déconcentration on a surtout besoin de
faire confiance aux femmes et aux hommes
qui préside aux destinées de nos
collectivités je pense notamment aux
communes au maire qu'on a souvent
tendance à solliciter a singulièrement
dans cette période de crise mais tout au
long de l'année parce qu'ils sont ceux
qui rythme la vie et le quotidien de nos
concitoyens et le moment commandes à ce
que nous leur fassions plus confiance
que nous puissions aller plus loin et
que l'on continue heures transférer plus
de pouvoir que ce soit au niveau de
l'éducation que ce soit au niveau de la
politique environnementale que ce soit
tout ce qui concerne l'accompagnement le
financement des communes c'est aussi le
cas sur des sujets très pratique et
comme le secteur éolien nous avons
souhaité que les maires puissent avoir
un droit de veto qui les protège une
prolifération de des éoliennes qui
s'installe par trop souvent de façon
anarchique sur sur nos territoires il y
a un besoin criant d'écouter les maires
pour justement leur permettre d'agir
plus fortement et surtout de prendre en
compte les spécificités de nos
territoires la différence qu'il ya entre
chacun de nos territoires et surtout de
pouvoir répondre avec agilité rapidité
aux demandes de nos concitoyens
[Musique]